foreign
hi Jessica welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um I think I maybe need some advice
um on our next step me and my husband
um are kind of torn he's one way I'm on
uh the other way we have been budgeting
for a long time well like five six years
now but we've always maintained debt uh
just because I know it sounds bad but we
can afford it
um but we're at a place where we don't
want to stay in the in the city that
we've been living in
um for the rest of our lives
um and
he wants to sell the house
uh use the equity you pay off everything
that we have kind of make a fresh start
rent for a while and then use the
leftover Equity that we have to put as
our saving fund and uh add to it until
we're ready to probably build a new
house
um
and use almost everything cash okay so
you're in Vegas you're in Vegas and
you're going to leave Vegas
yeah yeah so our jobs are here in Vegas
but we're looking at probably going to
uh Utah win um the commute
there's not a set date okay so why not
do it simultaneous with this whole thing
if you're gonna do that
what was that I said if you're going to
sell the house go to Utah now
okay why wouldn't you do is there a
reason you wouldn't do that she has an
option too yeah I know she doesn't want
to do that I'm just I'm trying to figure
out what they're doing well no I would
love to do that but we have uh we have
one kid and we both our job we work 48
hours straight and so his parents
um watch our child for us when we when
we do go to work and they live just down
the street from us and so you're not
going to Utah
not until his dad retires
and then they would probably pick up and
come with us oh
when is that and so
uh four to five years okay so this is
absolutely bullcrap the Utah thing
hasn't got anything to do with your son
your house now because four to five
years from now no one knows what's going
to happen and so you're not gonna rent
you're not gonna sell now and rent for
five years unless you're in a really
desperate pickle how much debt have you
all got and why have you been struggling
with it for five and a half years
well we just we've just been paying kind
of minimum payments every time just
because how much debt how much debt do
you have
um we have a HELOC
um and then cars and so it's about 140.
140 on the HELOC
and whatever
oh I'm sorry I'm gonna be on the HELOC
yeah 70 on the HELOC about 70 overall
for our vehicles okay what are y'all on
vehicle number one
uh about 40. okay and what are you on
vehicle number two
around 30 30. you have no other debt
other than two cars in a HELOC in a
house
uh we have one trailer
camping trailer of 16 000 bucks
yeah so you've not been struggling with
your budget you've been riding you've
been riding high on cars and enjoying
these cars and and had no ability and no
idea to pay them off what's your
household income
uh we make about 200 a year
[Music]
what's the what's the note on these cars
car one what's it monthly
what's the monthly payment on your cars
car one and car two I'm just curious
one is
one is about
one is I think 700 and the other 600.
there it is okay and uh um what's your
house worth
uh probably about
eight to eight hundred and fifty
thousand and what do you owe on it
480. okay all right so um do you want me
to do you called and asked I wanna so I
want to double check do you do you want
me to tell you the truth
are you sure
yes okay
I would keep my house
and quit being a couple of two hundred
thousand dollar a year spoiled freaking
brats
and I would pay ten thousand dollars a
month on this debt and be done in 14
months but you guys spend like you're in
Congress you buy anything you want to
buy whenever you want to buy it there is
zero control at this house
okay and you guys have really got a
button down
you're are you 28
yes yeah almost like I've done this
before okay so yeah that that's what I
was gonna that you fit the pattern yeah
I fit the pattern you have you've
excelled in your career and it made you
financially lazy lazy you make too much
money to be this broke yeah that's
called skinny fat
okay so was that too mean for you
no okay all right you can do this
Jessica you guys you guys are in a
really good position you have a good
life you have good cars you have a good
house you have a good income and yet
you're broke yeah and so you're in a
really good position to get control of
this money monster before it owns you
because one flip of the switch on the
career one flip the switch the real
estate market and this is gonna turn it
on you guys I know it happened to me
when I was exactly your age only I was
dumber than you I had more zeros on it
than you got on it so you guys really
need to get on a written detail plan
with no eating out no vacations until we
get all this freaking stuff paid off and
or we need to sell all of it yeah not
counting the house yeah what's the deal
with that trailer yeah I think you can
pay it off in 14 months ten thousand
dollars a month that's a you know you
make two hundred thousand you can do
that but this is going to mean you have
no life except getting out of debt but
in a little over a year you could be
free how does that sound
he sounds really good would you really
go do it
uh yeah I think we could I think my my
husband's just he's I think he's more on
the it'd be easier if we just sold and
start fresh but it wouldn't change you
it wouldn't change the person in your
house mirror and this process of 14
months of sacrifice y'all are never
going to be the same you're going to be
a different level of maturity than you
ever dreamed of when you come out the
other side of this you got to be careful
with these high incomes I call it skinny
fat because it's that same idea of I've
got this High income and it's an
illusion that I can do what I want it's
like when you're thin and you think you
can eat McDonald's every day and it's
not messing you up because you haven't
put on a bunch of weight but meanwhile
it's messing you up on the inside heart
disease metabolism high cholesterol it's
messing with your metabolism skinny fat
just because it looks healthy and it
looks great doesn't mean that it
actually is You Gotta Do the Right
habits no matter what the situation with
your income yeah you got a real
opportunity here to turn everything
around and keep your house and I think
you'll end up 10 years from now in a
better State financially if you do that
at than if you just sell the house and
clean off the debt because the debt will
grow back because you didn't change